[Music]
guys look we all know that eSports isn't
always about skill or strategy some of
our favorite plays of all-time weren't
born from someone out playing or out
thinking their opponents they were born
from a little luck I'm gonna steal this
oh no don't get me wrong the plays that
we're counting down definitely require
skilled and execute they just shouldn't
have been possible first place today
we're paying respect to those times when
our and Jesus took the wheel times when
someone pulled off something that should
have been mathematically impossible
today we're counting down eSports is top
10 one in a million place kicking off
our list is attached showing us that
sometimes you just need a little spark
of madness to pull off the unthinkable
stuck in a 1v3 during the cwl Pro League
stage one Grand Finals attach runs
through a friendly artillery strike
something no one in their right mind
would ever attempt a play like this
should never work
the comeback seems to be dead the
comeback seems eww runs to his own
artillery he not only survives but takes
down the three remaining opponents and
puts phase on tournament points all
through a true one coming in at number
nine is this spicy play from Illidan
during the group stage of the starladder
enmity v dota 2 miner season 1
after killing notail Illidan finds
himself being routed and dropped down to
literally one HP tops ins Monkey King
chases the bleeding PA out of the base
but thanks to a few lucky crits Illidan
goes from hunted to hunter once PA gets
her alt both her auto attacks and dagger
ability have a 15% chance to crit for an
insane amount of damage seriously just
look at this
oh you can't stop this man coming in at
number eight is London Spitfires prophet
who pulls off a truly one-in-a-million
headshot prophet teleports off of an
allied Symetra portal and gets the snipe
of his alight lurker drops and while
this may look like just a simple pick at
the start of the game take a closer look
and you'll see the gestures second
Orissa shield lands slightly behind
Zenyatta 's head exposing him to a widow
in the wrong place at the wrong time
right here so gonna look at first and
they just what was that she was trying
to peek around the barrier to volley and
pavol takes our number seven spot and
his run at the 2016 hearthstone World
Championship shows that sometimes you
just need R and G to get the win after
his opponent amnesiac plays one of the
strongest legendary cards malygos Pavel
plays babbling book a spell that adds a
random age spell to his hand he gets
poly more
be perfect answer to the malygos this is
gonna blow bubble and these checks are
you how off the water oh look at oh my
god the heartbreak on the face rounded
oh yeah hold his own hair a little bit
they was so frustrated a turn later he
is faced with another major threat but
he draws another battling book and once
again he gets exactly violence Paul to a
number tube she can't just fire lands
Paul to Dane Dane digging its way to
number six is a GM's multicast Fire
Blast against evil geniuses during the
group stage of the International 2016 eg
are just moments away from destroying
alliances throne and ending the game but
with his back against the wall egn
manages to pull out a mirror can they
close it universe desperately smurfy
calling did a [ __ ]
you know ger majors ultimate gives any
of his basic spells a chance to double
triple or quadruple cast
can't make clothes that universe
desperately scrapie following Jane Jane
Jane [ __ ] he goes down to an
alliance find the triple die back to
shut down eg and they death affect the
other way no way I can't believe they
couldn't finish the game there there's
so much coming into the halfway point in
our list is armadas insane turn of
orangy during the Smash summit 2 against
axe our mana is on his last stock versus
axe and needs to mount a comeback all it
takes is a little help from our in Jesus
he starts by getting a bomb which has a
0.26%
oh come on this game game you know
honestly a lot of peaches right now will
actually throw and then pulls a stitch
face now there's only a 1.71 1% chance
of that habit
[Applause]
and then against all long trooper gets
Anita - but he's going for it all that
is holy merciful
through incredible feats of orangy
Armada is able to win the game and
eventually the series it's the anguish
of a man who just saw acts constitutive
a 6-10 billows can I just say it that
was new bombs stitch smeb alts and
steals his way onto our list at number
four during Game five of the 2016 lck
summer finals Katie get a pic on roxas
jungler peanuts which should guarantee
them a baron and put them in a good
position to win the series plot gets
killed Katie turns immediately on the
Baron now smeb lays down his gangplank
ultimate to try to deter Katie but
manages to do so much more here at
fighting sir perhaps I've seen why
Barret taken
steal in a tragic missplay Katie's
jungler score smites the baron a little
early and the rest is history
falling into the number-3 spot is
simples legendary play during the ESL
one cologne 2016 7 fox double smokes in
the same place in what looks like a
one-round for fnatic simple takes his op
and does what only simple can do simple
I dunno - for our number 2 entry we go
to the 2016 League of Legends World
Championship semi-finals between the
rocks tigers and SKT with prey & Kuro in
SK T's base and both teams split across
the map these two players realize that
they have a chance to keep pushing so a
sketchy know that rocks can't get the
backup this is gonna be dangerous but
it's gonna keep running what's good for
this
get the proof of the strength to land
the kickback doesn't mean much to Blake
and I should be a kill on to the rocks
Tigers jungling but he's just my type
yeah pushing the bottom side dissuade
SKT is trying to punish me but he can
keep midlane alive because top and hip
has been killed and they even got the
pickoff on bank with the game on the
line prey fires the most unforgettable
arrow in League of Legends history been
killed and they even got the pickoff on
bank rocks doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls
[Applause]
and it works the ash arrow not only
stops Dukes teleport but it buys rocks
enough time to win the game pushing down
back on George spray a push back yet
again footsteps running whoa
you've probably guessed it already but
for the number one entry on our list we
are gonna talk about colds eras famous
jumping off you might have seen it
before
but this play is truly one in a minute
there's a lot of pressure on him he's
gotta hit these shots we saw floating
this in this spot before the same spot
with but with much more utility to work
with here he comes once again the first
base is attorneys gonna hit the ground
there's cold
after picking off a dren coldzera
proceeds to get a jumpin noscope
collateral on a leash and simple and
then no scopes nitro for what is
probably the most amazing 4k in csgo
history now everyone knows that
lightning doesn't strike twice unless
you're called Zahra and in that case it
strikes three times well guys there you
have it ten plays that were truly
one-in-a-million if you think we're
one-in-a-million you can like the video
and if you subscribe you will be one in
our million subs that is one of I got
away
I gotta own the cheese
[Music]